Matt Walsh joins us tonight Matt Walsh
thank you so much
and for among other things illustrating
how journalism can be a force for good I
think yours has been have you spoken to
anyone at Vanderbilt Hospital about this
directly
oh Vanderbilt Hospital I mean we we
reached out for a statement when we
first published the report and at first
they didn't want to give a statement and
they and they actually just took down as
you mentioned they just deleted so
people have to understand they deleted
their entire transgender Clinic website
they wiped it from existence and then
today not to us but uh in general they
released the statement and the
interesting thing about the statement
they released is that they do not while
they start by claiming there's
misinformation and so on they don't
actually factually dispute anything in
my report because they can't because
everything that I said wasn't me saying
it I was just providing video evidence
much of which you you played there well
we know for a fact this is an absolute
fact that that that Vanderbilt they
perform double mastectomies on minor
girls on children they chemically
castrate children and they give them
irreversible hormone drugs that change
their bodies permanently they're doing
all of that to kids and the other thing
we should know and I'm glad you
mentioned all the other hospitals around
the country because the things I just
mentioned that's happening all across
the country in every single state in in
many hospitals and in many other medical
clinics all of those things are
happening and one of the reasons why
it's allowed to keep happening is
because people don't know about it
because they're not talking about it and
I think for a lot of average
Americans people just walking down the
street it's sort of Unthinkable they
can't imagine that this sort of thing is
actually happening but it is which is
why we have to start by raising
awareness about it and we have to do
that no matter no matter the the game
the left plays by saying if you so much
as mention what they're doing it's
incitement and terrorism which is which
is absurd but uh we can't we can't bend
to that tactic we have to keep shining a
light on this cutting the breasts off
little girls
sterilizing 14 year olds like yeah okay
yeah we're not the criminals here and by
the way I've got to believe that not
everyone on the board at Vanderbilt
Medical Center is a bad person I've got
to believe a lot of these people that
had no idea this was happening and I
hope they know now and I hope they do
something tonight to end it I appreciate
your coming on and for all you've done
on this Matt Walsh thank you
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight